la mode aujourd'hui c'est de glorifier
le football féminin où la boxe féminine
y compris chez les féministes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que eux
les féministes veulent pas du tout que
les que les hommes se comportent comme
les femmes elles veulent que les femmes
se comportent comme les hommes elles
vont à l'encontre de ce que vous dites
effectivement et pour moi c'est un
problème c'est à dire qu'on valorise
dans notre société les comportements
viril c'est vrai on a de moins en moins
de problèmes à inscrire une petite fille
au football ou à la boxe qui est très à
la mode chez les femmes
par contre il y a une résistance autour
des valeurs viriles du côté des garçons
je prends souvent cet exemple on est en
2021 et on ne peut toujours pas mettre
un tee shirt rose à un petit garçon
ça paraît anodin et pourtant c'est
révélateur des résistances qu'il ya
autour de ça et dans un même mouvement
et ça c'est très important de le
comprendre le de la dévalorisation de
tout ce qui est dit féminin et pourtant
quand on regarde cette étude ces valeurs
qui sont transmises aux filles ses
valeurs dites féminines ont des effets
beaucoup plus positif sur la société
[Musique]